c'est fait concernant les gardes
d'enfants de ce type suscite
inévitablement une très vive émotion en
particulier quand l'un des parents
accuse l'autre de maltraitance physique
le tribunal a pris la décision c'est à
free de rejeter la demande
tu as dit que ça n'arriverait plus
l'avais promis je suis vraiment désolé
chaque pas dans l'idée d'emmener les
calmes parce que tu sais que tu enfin
rennes à lyon
téléspectateurs pour retrouver je suis
une mcpherson et s'est enfui après avoir
kidnappé ici deux enfants nous avons cru
comprendre que vous avez besoin d'être
au fait des besoins
je préfère éviter d'avoir à jouer les
héros l'activité est déjà suffisamment
risque je peux vous garder sur la faire
il suffit d'y mettre le prix
mille dollars retrouver mes enfants ils
subissent une sacrée pression de la part
de quelques heures j'ai cru comprendre
que c'est vous qui les mettaient en
danger
je ne rendrai pas les enfants avant
d'avoir remonté la filière jusqu'au
canada
on est jamais tenté de passer d'un camp
à l'autre
et moi on est liée pour toujours alors
tâchons de bien nous entendre on la
recherche activement
le droit qu'a situation vous dépasse
et un problème qui êtes vous
aucune idée de la véritable ampleur de
cette affaire jocelyne
me touchera un cheveu de mes enfants